yeah so uh on Wednesday of this week uh
Bethesda confirmed that redfall would be
launching on series consoles at 30 FPS
with a 60fps performance mode to be
added later via game update although
they did not give a time frame for said
update and
the internet went crazy okay as the
internet does as the internet does the
internet went crazy
um
I want to know what you guys think
because for me
in an adjustable in a just world this
should not be a big deal but it is
and obviously the one that
doesn't really go with the whole sort of
hey the game's done because of this but
I will say this
30 FPS at launch no 60fps performance
mode is an l